hello everyone uh good afternoon and
welcome to this talk
um so in today's talk I'm going to I'm
going to discuss more around how we
generate adversarial examples in the
field of fraud detection uh so my name
is nitin Sharma and I work in the
long-term research team at uh at PayPal
uh one of the things that we try to do
there is try to understand how fraud
patterns um in the financial technology
sector are evolving over time and uh one
of the hardest challenges there is you
know as as a part of predicting how they
evolve uh one of the challenges is can
we actually anticipate them ahead of
time there's a lot of seasonal Trend
there uh and also we see the attack
Vector actually varies quite a bit
depending on the type of uh uh the type
of transition you're looking at so for
example you have account takeover or you
have bank fraud or credit card fraud and
in that case the way the fraudsters are
trying to attack the system actually
varies quite a bit so the whole talk is
really about can we actually anticipate
ahead of time and generate adversarial
examples uh and then also see if you
could improve uh the uh the feedback
mechanism and then eventually the
detection fraud detection of algorithms
that we developed
so today's talk is outlined really into
broadly five different areas so uh we'll
start with the problem background and
just discuss the motivation as to why
this is important for us in the field of
fraud detection uh I'll just quickly
cover sort of the state state of the art
on the adversarial learning side of the
things and then also see how we are
adapting a lot of that state of the art
for this practical problem
uh we'll also look at attack generation
methods and defense methods so broadly
one use case for each type uh how do we
generate adversal attacks and then how
do we develop defense against those
adversal attacks so how do we do things
like adversary retrain online hard
example Mining and things like that and
last but not the least uh just
established some conclusions there
so um
the PayPal ecosystem generally and I
think this is true of most Financial
technology systems that have some kind
of fraud detection component to them so
you might find very broadly like five
different characteristics of this sort
of a system uh first it's heterogeneous
so what I mean by that is if you're
looking at uh at each customer
transaction and if you're looking at as
a simple multivariate Vector you'll find
that there's a lot of heterogeneity of
the distribution of that multivariate
Vector because you might have customers
that could be just people or just
businesses they're actually trying to do
a wide range of activities on the the
financial technology platform and then
they're also doing it online or
installed so you can actually see if you
try to just look at the multivariate
vector that um conditional as well as
unconditional so uh just basically given
that a fraud uh has occurred what's the
distribution of X that generates it or
just even the unconditional distribution
of X you'll find a lot of hydrogenity
there and this makes it hard because
there's also a lot of sparsity there
some distributions are super sparse some
of them actually have they actually
dominate the the overall distribution
Footwear it's also multi-objective in
nature so we want to be able to detect
fraudsters with different model super
anti uh but also at the same time we
want our good users to have as
frictionless experience as possible so
we want them to actually have sort of a
lightweight uh very very quick
adjudication that just helps them get
through the system fast enough so the
user experience stays uh pretty good uh
and then if if we have potential for
fraud then we maybe want to take a
second look at it instead of just taking
you know a very second hard look at
everything so there's also that criteria
uh the patterns are evolving temporarily
and systemically so a lot of traffic for
example would have been just through
desktop based systems or laptop-based
systems a few years ago but now it's
increasingly becoming a mobile based and
so you're seeing the systemic variation
and fraud pattern that occurs but also
there's temporal variation things
actually change a lot with time and so
then it becomes harder to actually
continue to model and detect uh that
broad pattern uh and then there's also
imbalance so bulk of the users are good
users and uh you know you have this
small fraction of users that would be
fraudulent and they vary quite a bit in
the way they're attacking the system so
and the source of Truth itself is
delayed so when we are trying to assess
a fraud pattern uh you might have a
certain time lag between which you
actually uh perform the transaction and
then got the result back from the system
as to whether this is fraudulent or not
and then there's also a lot of domain
knowledge and segmentation that goes in
just to keep improving the last mile
so this is just a very broad footprint
of the different fraud patterns uh
mostly stolen identity and stolen
financials um you know somebody's
account that gets taken over by uh by a
fraudster and then he starts monetizing
from that PayPal account adds you know
fraudulent funding instruments and
things like that so Inspirations where
fraudsters might just add things that
they found from the dark web and then
start monetizing from there so stolen
financials again can be classified into
card based bank-based fraud and so on so
identity financials and then also
there's one more on the side of bank
fraud where you know Fosters may not
have enough money to fund a transaction
uh and they still go ahead with it
anyway and then we've we figured out
later that there wasn't enough money to
fund that purchase so so you have that
kind of fraud pattern there as well and
then on the then you also have the
credit fraud and credit risk uh which
sort of is less problematic when it
comes to temporal variations and also in
terms of uh uh you know complexity of
the modeling systems so fraud usually
you could model the system through
complex architectures the credit we have
constraints because there's more
explainability overhead
so uh very quickly so we'll look at
adversarial learning so what are we
trying to do here so what we're really
trying to do is uh basically so a
fraudster typically will try to log into
the system or try to perform an attack
and uh maybe the machine learning
algorithm is smart enough to block the
fraudster right then and there so then
what happens the processor goes back and
tries to change certain attributes of
the attack vector and then tries to
breach the system again and this time
it's possible that the model actually
allows the fraudster to to gain access
and then eventually perform the attack
itself uh so then again going back to
the classic definition you have an input
and you're applying intentional
perturbations to the input so how do you
perturb the input then becomes very
important and then you also then discern
whether the input now breaches the
decision boundary so now that you've
changed the input if you go back to the
same modeling architecture are you able
to get a different decision from an
approved from a decline to maybe an
approve this time and then perturbations
are could be just basic noise vectors
that you could add through careful
optimization and this is really where we
spend bulk of the time what kind of
optimization method should we use to to
develop realistic attacks and so a
classic idea here is if you look at
traditional back propagation you're
basically uh when you're training a
model you're basically uh you know
differentiating the loss function uh
effectively uh by keeping the input
constant so effectively allow the model
parameters to vary uh and then you're
trying to minimize the loss function
with adversary learning you basically
have the model parameters being the same
but you're differentiating again the
loss function with respect to the input
because you want to change the input
here and the idea is to maximize the
loss function instead of minimizing it
so in the first case you're minimizing
the loss function because you want to
find a model that best fits the uh the
the construct of Y to X but in this case
we are trying to maximize the loss so we
can find the directions in which the
attack Vector should change so you can
get the best resolution on fraud on
creating these adversal examples
right so let's actually look at what
that means to fraud right so one is
fraudsters can change status scope they
could change things like IP device
browser location in some cases platforms
uh so they could change all of those
things so first thing is what could they
change right if they were coming back
and reaching the system and then the
second thing is uh if they don't change
things sometimes what happens is they
might just try to build trust with the
system so they might come in do a few
small dollar value transactions that
might be conducted maybe over a month or
a few months and then this is your way
to figure out that okay the system now
trusts you more the variables and
attributes that are related to that
particular account might be flagging
towards trust and now the attack the
fraudster might be ready to perform a
full-blown attack so there's also that
problem where you could have small
dollar value transactions or the large
ones so the idea here or the question
that we're posing is can we generate
these adversible examples uh where the
model actually previously approved the
transaction and then upon the change of
the attack Vector actually then actually
previously declined it and then
eventually changed the decision to
approve
so um why is this an important problem
really uh or how do perturbations in
this area uh pose challenges right so if
you look at traditional image or text
problems uh the way you perform the
perturbation for example you have that
image there and now you could basically
perform uh sort of a perturbation along
some kind of a norm right so you could
basically take some kind of a norm
Vector on the image vector and then
effectively add that on top and then of
course use constructs such as fast
gradient sign method where you would
find what's the right extent of
perturbation you want to perform in
order to get uh get the classifier to
classify an image that for example could
be a duck but now to classify it as
horse because now you have added a
little bit of noise to that image or
some sort of a non perturbation to that
image same thing with speech you perform
some perturbation and then you get uh
basically a different classification
there with fraud basically what happens
is uh so I'm just giving an example here
of for example a variable that is
related to the country code right so the
attack for example in this case maybe
actually was launched from from the US
and you get a vector which is actually a
combination of continuous features and
categorical features right and uh what
might happen here is if you just perturb
it based on basically a very simple
naive non-base method you might find an
attack that is unrealistic so for
example in the in that scenario what you
saw is previously uh the user was
branded as fraudulent and the country
code which would be one of the bins in
your categorical features maybe reflects
the country location of U.S now if you
if the if you could realistically
generate a perturbation where that
country code or the bin for the category
actually changes from us to some other
country but then the question is is this
a realistic attack because the froster
wouldn't really change the location
there in order to launch this attack so
the biggest problem here is how do you
constrain your attack vector and uh
that's what we uh that that hopefully
should be the biggest uh sort of uh
challenge here for uh for this talk uh
as to how do you generate realistic
perturbations especially given the fact
that you have continuous features and
categorical features
yeah so this is sort of a general uh you
know outlook on how we actually uh
intend to perform these attacks one is
at inference time where we carefully
perturb the input at inference time or
poisoning where you could inject bad
examples at training path
um in general when you look at fraud
patterns you have essentially a fraud
pattern that's on ACH or or bank account
that's what we are looking at here and
the approach is we are basically looking
at selected adversal examples uh but
we're also looking at we're also taking
into consideration some domain know-how
because we know that some of our
examples might be more prone to adversal
attack as compared to some others
so uh very broadly uh there are a wide
array of adversarial example generation
methods in the literature uh most of
them are categorized as block black box
or white box and either derivative based
methods like I was describing earlier
first gradient sign method or iterative
optimization based methods which are
more non-linear optimization methods
like lbfgs and so on so uh so the idea
that we have here or the the experiment
that we attempted here was basically to
take the examples that come from a large
training data set and perform a wide
array of perturbations using different
approaches and the reason why we do that
is because each approach optimizes for a
different cost function or different
objective it perturbs the uh the
underlying input Vector in a different
way and what we wanted to do was instead
of just utilizing one or one or more
method or maybe a combination of one or
two methods to see if we could subject
our model to the most to the hardest
challenges essentially so we have a two
level optimization stage here where we
first do an ensemble of adversarial
portable patients then we also have
constraints on top of those
perturbations so like I said we
restricted our search space to realistic
uh attack vectors or subset of vectors
that would be realistic and so there
were some I mean I could talk a little
bit more about how we discern those but
the idea here is to pick something that
you know reflects the past history of
that account if we have any kind of
history there
and then the second level optimization
was generatively learning so now that
you have the attack vectors that are
launched here uh now generatively
learning basically the cohort that
reaches it to the to the best extent uh
so here uh we are basically looking for
which methods are leading to the largest
change in decisions uh but with the
smallest perturbations
so this is just basically some results
on individual methods and then The
Ensemble methods and the way you
interpret it is uh this is basically the
ratio of the champion Motor Performance
to the performance of the model after it
was breached basically with the
adversarial approaches and uh we found
that the Ensemble approach where we
actually use a combination of these uh
is actually not only better performing
on this data set but also temporarily uh
you have five time periods that we have
actually looked at and we also looked at
other methods like confidence interval
and bootstrapping to just ensure that we
have a reliable estimate of performance
here
the other part on the adversarial
retrain uh very quickly here is how do
you make your model more robust as a
result of that so what we do here is
basically we have a two-stage training
process where we basically feed forward
freeze the feed forward in the first
iteration freeze the network uh the
adversal examples were identified in the
previous method so we use those
adversarial examples as seed uh and then
we create a mini batch based on
variations but bottom line here is you
could think of this as a mini batch that
optimizes for the hardest adversarial uh
examples and then what we do is uh the
last stage when we unfreeze we only back
propagate the hard examples or the
examples that actually uh bear from the
adversarial perturbations and obviously
this process actually is to be done
carefully because we don't want to
change the model performance too much
and tune it too much to the adversarial
uh interface so so there is definitely
that aspect this is a very quick review
of a performance Outlook there we're
also looking at temporal stability there
to make sure that it's stable across
time
and yeah so broadly we see that this
area is still an area of research for
for us and uh it continues to be
adversary examples are hard to generate
especially given the constrainted
scenario and fraud detection uh but we
are seeing some promising results here
uh in making our models relatively more
robust uh so hopefully we have some
context here but I'm also happy to take
any specific questions here
thank you
[Applause]
practically
yeah so I think we have I think we have
some reliable data from a supervised
context for example
um uh you know if there are instances
that come in from the same property
maybe the same account or it could also
be some other properties that would be
either for example the IP address or the
certain combination of keys that you
could reasonably well identify that yeah
these were a series of declines that
happened and then there was a successive
approval uh so so usually we have some
supervision supervised data that's
available for us to go back into the
system and figure out that yeah it seems
like there's a good sequence of event
history that's coming in from this
particular asset and eventually you'd
like to have Google and finally we also
have the virtual tag so after the
transaction was approved you also get a
label back from the system whether it's
on the account takeover or a bank or a
car from so we try to use the full loop
there's some
credit scores
cyber security support yes that is
yeah so I think generally I mean I think
the industry state of the art I think we
find ourselves uh pretty much at the you
know
uh here also there are different use
cases because PayPal as a product
actually is is addressing a wide array
of uh of transaction right you're
looking at cross-border transactions
also within when we have Benmore which
is a very different system and PayPal
but still is a part of that model so
obviously the overall PayPal subsidiary
so I think eventually we find ourselves
to be at pretty much at the top because
we also do some of the benchmarking with
credit uh based domains because there's
a personality credit and for domains
there
um yeah but I think from an adversible
point of view I have to say this is
still an area that is still evolving uh
very gradually for us
metrics
yeah so uh so so far I think we are
looking very largely at so what we do
have ideas that are around uh false
positive ratios like because we also
want to ensure that these adversible
methods don't end up leaving an
excessive decline of good users so what
we often do is we typically you look at
measures like operating characteristics
but here we try to constrain ourselves
to a lower region and then see uh how
our essentially our false positive to to
positive ratios actually vary uh and
then how do they vary across the spec
not just for the episodes
foreign
and she's going to tell us about
sequential decision making problems